tu es politiques ce matin c'est barbara
conflits liés bonjour bonjour si
beaucoup d'être avec nous est mise et la
transition écologique on est ensemble
pendant un peu plus de vingt minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale
représenté par fabrice veysseyre aux
dons bonjour fabrice bonjour auriol
bureau pour lui et moi les journaux
régionaux de l'est de la france aura
bien sûr longuement parlé de la loi
climat barbares bon public est
actuellement en examen au sénat
mais d'abord l'actualité et l'actualité
c'est l'eurodéputé socialiste pierre
larrouturou et le réalisateur ces
réunions qui ont porté plainte contre
jean castex et quatre ministres dont
vous pour inaction climatique qui selon
eux met des milliers personnes en danger
comment vous réagissez à cette plainte
je sais pas comment réagir face à une
opération de communication
c'est la comédie côté moi ce que je
regarde c'est les actions qui sont mises
en place il porte plainte contre eux
quoi quand les 30 milliards pour la
transition écologique qui sont en plan
de relance contre la fermeture des
centrales à charbon contre la loi climat
les et des feux contre fait je ne sais
pas contre quoi ils portent plainte
par contre moi je ne les entend pas
beaucoup quand je me bats pour la
transition écologique et pour développer
l'éolien je sais pas où ils sont j'ai
une version je sais pas où ils sont pour
défendre les zones anti pollution dans
les villes qui font débat et où on a
besoin aussi que les défenseurs de
l'environnement se mobilise pas
seulement dans ces la supplication ce
que la politique pour maintenance et de
la communication comment vous vivez ça
vous personnellement vous avez été
il est ainsi qu'aux deux systèmes
souvient de votre parcours quand vous
êtes attaqués aujourd'hui nommément en
tant que ministre pour inaction
comment vous vivez ça justement je suis
militante écologiste depuis 20 ans donc
on ne me la fait pas entre guillemets je
sais ça fait mal je sais je sais
pourquoi je me bats je sais pourquoi je
suis là je sais que je fais avancer tout
ce que je peux je sais que je me bats
tous les jours pour défendre l'avenir de
nos enfants et notre avenir
donc après si vous venez pour moi le
reste c'est de la mousse cette plante du
coup ne va rien changer à votre
politique
non vous savez moi je fais la part des
choses on a besoin d'avoir des personnes
des ong des associations qui nous
titille qui nous alerte qui nous pousse
à aller plus loin qui met en lumière un
certain nombre de problèmes je pense que
c'est très utile et c'est très utile
pour le débat démocratique
donc qu'ils continuent à nous titiller a
demandé de répondre et à quelque part à
new challenge et pour qu'on aille encore
plus loin
aucun problème pour le reste franchement
je suis au travail d'eric à cette
plainte qui a été déposée il ya hier
aussi un tribunal belge qui a condamné
l'état fédéral belge et les trois
régions du pays pour faute faute en
menant une politique climatique
négligeons c'est ce qui a été dit c'est
une décision inédite dans le pays
est-ce qu entre la plante contre vous ce
qui s'est passé hier on va vers une
judiciarisation des questions
écologiques et est ce que vous le
déplorez je crois pas un trop longtemps
le droit de l'environnement a été
négligée et on s'est battus est
d'ailleurs encore une action qui a été
mis en place par par ce gouvernement
c'est pas parfait ce qu'on fait mais en
tout cas on avance on a mis en place un
juge de l'environnement
un parc et de l'environnement qui vont
pouvoir justement mieux traiter ces
questions là qui avant était un peu le
parent pauvre de la justice ensuite on a
une volonté aussi de mettre très haut
dans notre constitution la protection de
l'environnement du climat il ya un
projet de loi constitutionnelle qui
encourt de passage entre les deux
assemblées
voilà donc de vous pensez qu'il va
aboutir d'ailleurs puisqu'on en parle ce
projet de loi constitutionnelle moi en
tout cas je pense qu'on ne peut pas se
permettre sur un sujet aussi important
de montrer qu'on n'est pas capable de se
mettre d'accord
donc on a là l'assemblée nationale le
sénat qui ont cette responsabilité en
main de trouver la juste voie et moi je
crois en tant qu'ancien des
parlementaires je crois j'espère qu'ils
vont à trouver comment on fait pas ce
qu'est ce que vous êtes prêts à faire un
compromis sur la version du sénat où est
ce que vous dites ça sera la version de
l'assemblée nationale ou rien vous savez
le sénat tient à priori de ce que j'ai
compris des débats au terme
la référence à la charte de
l'environnement à l'assemblée nationale
ils tiennent aux homos de garantir
peut-être qu'on peut trouver des moyens
de trouver une rédaction qui soit juste
et qui permettent de satisfaire tout le
monde
moi je crois qu'on doit avancer bon sang
c'est une cause qui nous concerne tous
on est dans le même bateau
on doit être capable de trouver des
chemins donc vous dit le sénateur
accepter le mot garantiert parce qu'ils
ne sont pas pour le mot garantir et vous
dit aux députés accepter la référence à
la charte de l'environnement
oui en tout cas parler vous ai trouvé
des solutions de bon sens on va parler
de l'autre actualité qui vous concerne
et c'est cette pollution aux
hydrocarbures qui a été constaté en
corse depuis plusieurs jours ça a touché
plusieurs plages de l'île pollution liée
à un dégazage sauvage
est ce qu'aujourd'hui tout nouveau
risque de pollution est écartée sur
l'île alors d'abord vous l'avez dit on
est sur la délinquance environnementale
caractérisée l'enquêté est en cours et
je compte bien que les responsables de
ça soit à raisonner et payent très cher
ce qu'ils ont fait parce que à un moment
il faut montrer que c'est un supporter l
oms est courant on sait quoi de l'anc
est là pour l'instant il y à il y a eu
un certain nombre de
bateaux qui ont été identifiés comme
étant potentiellement les bateaux qui
qui ont provoqué ce dégazage un certain
nombre c'est combien alors on était
arrivé à troyes la semaine dernière la
ddt enquête sur 21 au départ et l
enquête l enquête se continue la honte
rabat en avant des mois aujourd'hui oui
on travaille en train on est on est à 3
après jeu il y a évidemment l' enquête
qui se poursuit
on est en lien avec nos collègues
européens puisque ce sont des bateaux
qui vont sur des porcs ils sont pas
forcément des ports français mais l'
enquête avance et j'ai bon espoir que
tout ça soit résolu dans les plus brefs
délais pensez pouvoir retrouver ce
bateau oui tout à fait tout à fait et
puis surtout faire en sorte que de leur
faire passer l'idée de recommencer et de
pas donné l'idée à d'autres de d'essayer
ce genre de bêtises et comment vous
faites parce qu'aujourd'hui sur le
papier il ya des sanctions qui peuvent
aller jusqu'à 10 en prison jusqu'à 15
millions d'âmes en deçà apparaît non et
pourtant on voit c'est pas dissuasif
il faut faire quoi pour vous pour pour
dissuader ces bateaux de faire ça mais
qu'est ce que vous attendez comme son
clone dans ce cas précis faire des
exemples il faut qu' il faut que ces
bateaux voix ils font ça pourquoi ils
font ça pour faire des économies
parce que ils doivent faire ce dégazage
c'est ce qu'on appelle les eaux grises
qui sont dans les moteurs comme moteur à
tourner ça reste dans les cales et à un
moment il faut vider les cales ya tous
les porcs sont équipés pour cela il
suffit d'y aller simplement soit un coût
donc et ça peut même monter très haut ça
peut monter jusqu'à 60 mille euros pour
les énormes bateaux porte conteneurs
donc ils vont ils ont pas envie de payer
ça donc ils des gaz en mer comme ça ni
vu ni connu
et puis tout le monde est content non on
est pas content quand on vient polluer
la méditerranée quand on vient quand on
vient surtout sur des zones comme la
corse mais autour où on a les herbiers
de posidonie qu'ils sont sains
des éléments d'écosystèmes hyper
important pour pour la méditerranée
c'est pas ça on fait pas n'importe quoi
donc ils seront lourdement sanctionnés
après les attendait comme sanction et
comme exemple qu est-ce que pour vous il
faut qu'il y ait pour sa montre
l'exemple et que s'additionnent
je sais c'est pas à moi de faire la
justice mais ce que vous l'avez dit
vous-même il peut y avoir des amendes
très élevées il peut y avoir des peines
de prison prononcées
moi je souhaite que tout ça soit très
sévère mais encore une fois c'est pas
mon rôle c'est le rôle de la justice sur
la la pollution du coup encore c'est ce
que pour vous je alors sur l'accord
risque est écarté au point sur la corse
les opérations de pompage quand même
permis de récupérer une grosse partie de
la nappe
il y a eu quelques galettes qui sont
arrivées sur les plages mais comme il ya
une mobilisation très forte des
différentes des différents services de
l'état et des collectivités
la sécurité civile et c'est que je salue
d'ailleurs ça à puce a été ramassé très
très vite donc on n'a plus à ce stade de
pollution sur les plages maintenant ça
peut il peut y avoir des résurgences qui
reviennent parce que vous savez que
c'est en fait ça tombe dans l'eau et
puis si l'eau se réchauffe ça peut
remonter donc on n'est pas à l'abri mais
à ce stade je crois qu'on a limité
fournira de nouvelles boulettes des pots
cassés au parrain possible c'est pas
impossible mais on est dans quelque
chose d'assez maîtrisée où vous voyez si
ça arrive ça peut être enlever tout de
suite on n'est pas sur l'erika donc
relativisons on n'est pas sur l'erika on
n'est pas sûr du fioul lourd
on est sur des eaux grises c'est
scandaleux ce qui s'est passé mais grâce
à la mobilisation de tout le monde on a
réussi à limiter à mesure qu'il n'aura
pas d'impact environnemental de cette
pollution sur l'île ou car il ya
toujours un impact il ya toujours un
impact et pas forcément sur l'île s'ils
ont réussi à limiter les arrivées sur
les plages
en revanche ce qui a coulé dans la mer
eh bien ça et toof ça étouffe la nature
ça étouffe les herbiers ça passe dans la
nourriture des poissons
donc non ce n'est pas une bonne chose
mais encore une fois relativisons nous
avons réussi à pomper quand même
beaucoup
un dernier mot là dessus parce que la
collectivité territoriale de corse a
porté plainte
est-ce qu'elle ait eu raison de le faire
pour vous bien sûr à la raison est ce
que l'état va faire de même mais nous de
toute façon il ya des poursuites qui
sont engagés encore une fois donc
ne vous inquiétez pas enfin vous pouvez
être vigilant mais je peux vous dire que
tout le monde est sur le pont pour les
retrouver vous avez convoqué en
parallèle à cette affaire des
responsables d'un navire d'un chantier
dans la baie de saint brieuc sur un
chantier d'un parc éolien suite à une
fuite d'huile
il va y avoir des suites judiciaires oui
le procureur de la république a été
saisi
si nous avons besoin mais un besoin
vital de développer les énergies
renouvelables et de ne pas louper le
coche par dans l'expression sur l'éolien
en mer nous sommes très en retard il ya
5000 mah qui sont installés un peu
partout en mer en europe et nous on en a
zéro on est en retard
il faut qu'on rattrape ce retard et on
doit lancer les travaux
mais j'ai dit depuis longtemps qu'il
fallait que ça se fasse de manière
absolument irréprochable et donc quand
on a ce genre d'incidents qui arrive ça
jette l'opprobre et ça jette la
suspicion sur tous les travaux qui sont
en train d'être faits sur les parcs
éoliens donc j'ai évidemment convoqué le
responsable de l'entreprise pour lui
signifier que c'était absolument
inadmissible que évidemment il devait
prendre ses responsabilités faire
réparer son bateau et revenir très vite
pour se continuer les travaux de manière
encore une fois il rédigé par un acte
volontaire contrairement à la course
ah non non non non non nast s'éteint
c'est un accident
c'est un accident mais qui est qu'ils
aient dû très certainement au fait qu'
on n'a pas regardé s'il me 6
suffisamment les signaux faibles
est ce qu'il y avait déjà eu des petites
fuites avant ça n'a pas été réglé tout
de suite donc ça ce n'est pas normal
donc pour ça que je vous ai convoqué et
donc y aura des sanctions
et donc il y aura le procureur est saisi
on verra ce qu'il fera est ce que c'est
un coup dur quand même pour l'éolien en
mer vous le dites on est déjà très en
retard sur la question de l'éolien en
mer est ce que là c'est un coup dur est
ce que c'est pas donner du grain à
moudre de tracteurs de l'éolien en mer
dans c'est une péripétie c'est une
péripétie nouvelles dont franchement je
me serais bien passé ça permet de
rappeler à tout le monde les règles les
règles c'est qu'on doit être
irréprochable
c'est simple on va parler de l'éolien
justement puisque le sénat examinant le
disait la loi climat en ce moment même
et cette nuit
un débat assez tendue au sénat sur cette
question est des rôles yen les sénateurs
ont donné un droit de veto aux communes
pour s'opposer à l'implantation
d'éoliennes
ainsi que la possibilité d'organiser un
référendum local pour consulter la
population qu est ce que vous avez pensé
de ce vote un droit de veto au maire une
certaine manière ce que j'ai pensé c'est
que on prend le débat par le mauvais
bout on a un besoin aujourd'hui de
développer les énergies renouvelables
alors j'ai entendu ça a commencé assez
vite à se focaliser sur un débat pro ou
anti nucléaires et anti-éoliens le pro
éoliens il faut regarder les choses en
face nous avons des scénarios devant
nous pour l'évolution de notre mix
électrique qui sont notamment expertise
et en ce moment par rte c'est par des
gens sérieux c'est pas c'est pas par des
politiciens 1
on a des scénarios avec plus ou moins de
nucléaire dans l'avenir puisque ça cc
c'est un peu ça le sujet même même le
scénario le point où il ya le plus de
nucléaire c'est un scénario où on
développe fortement les énergies
renouvelables on en a besoin
et parmi les énergies renouvelables on a
besoin de l'éolien donc il faut déjà
avoir ça en tête pour essayer de sortir
des faux débat ensuite on a besoin de
concertation
ça a pu être mal fait sur certains
territoires me suis dans la somme donc
j'ai vu ce qui se passait il ya des
procédures qui existent et d'ailleurs la
président de la commission du débat
public le rappelait hier dans la presse
il ya des procédures qui existent
simplement ça a pu mal se passer donc là
la méthode que je propose c'est de
reprendre les choses à zéro de faire une
cartographie qui était demandé par de
nombreux élus cartographie des zones où
on peut faire de l'éolien est ensuite
décliné les objectifs de renouvelables
sur les territoires et de regarder tous
ensemble de mettre tout le monde autour
net pour savoir où on peut les mettre on
peut pas les maîtres verriers de cette
histoire de veto ça veut dire quoi en
fait ça veut dire qu'on va mettre la
pression sur les maires c'est les maires
qui vont se retrouver avec cette
pression est long de cette possibilité
d'être un peu pris en otage par
certaines associations par certains
groupes alors qu'eux ils ont aussi droit
à faire partie de ceux qui vont être
consultés et qui pourront donner leur
avis mais là on
moi je trouve que c'est un cadeau
empoisonné confié au maire et qui en
plus peut poser des problèmes parce que
dans l'absurde
parce que ça n'existerait pas mais dans
l'absurde si si toutes les communes de
france donnait un veto moi ça fait quoi
on retournera la bougie on n'aurait pas
ce que les vétos on les aurait aussi sur
les autres énergies
si vous voyez ce qui se passe sur la
méthanisation pour mettre des nouvelles
centrales nucléaires à nosy pour mettre
même des panneaux photo native tout ça
n'est pas sérieux
donc moi je trouve que cette pression
est dommage alors qu'on a d'autres
manières de faire je voulais dit la
concertation puis aussi l'association
des citoyens
on a vu en france y compris que les
communautés énergétique citoyenne ça
marche quand les citoyens les riverains
sont associés y compris financièrement
au développement des énergies éoliennes
quand ils participent
et bien quand ils investissent eh bien
ça se passe bien et tout le monde est
content donc maïs il vous deviendrez pas
cet article essayons de trouver des
solutions avec marché des solutions
positives
arrêtons d'opposer les uns aux autres
ces débats actuellement sur l'éolien
sont des débats délétère moi je suis
très heureuse de voir que finalement
grâce au fait qu'ils n'osent qui sont
sortis mais le débat a fini par
s'installer de manière intéressante les
journalistes ont fait leur travail
on a eu des faits news qui ont été
démontés puis au fur et à mesure on a
commencé à créer un débat qui est
intéressant où l'on parle encore enfin
des faits des enjeux est-ce que c'est
uniquement un débat dès l'été est ce que
c'est pas un vrai débat qui est en train
de monter notamment dans les territoires
notamment dans les territoires ruraux
puisque on va pas se mentir c'est dans
ces territoires inconnus sont installées
les éoliennes est ce que vous ne
craignez pas que ça risque d'engendrer
une nouvelle fracture à un mouvement de
colère type gilet jaune
bah ça dépend de la manière dont 6 gérer
moi je considère que la transition
écologique à penser intimant de la part
des populations de ces territoires de
dire bon on décide depuis paris de nous
mettre des éoliennes dans notre champ de
vision c'est pas eux qui vont les subir
c'est nous et on nous impose quelque
chose dans finalement et les citadins
vivent
dans des endroits où il ya de la
pollution vivent dans des endroits où il
ya du bruit vivent dans un genre on peut
encore une fois essayé d'opposer les uns
aux autres on a tous des avantages et
des inconvénients des lieux où on vit
l'important c'est de faire en sorte que
tout le monde puisse avoir son mot à
dire sur la maison ça se passe et que
personne ne soit laissé pour compte
moi ce qui m'importe le plus c'est que
toutes les mesures que je prends sur la
transition écologique dans la loi ou
dans les mesures réglementaires sont des
mesures qui sont systématiquement
accompagnés par exemple on va mettre en
place les zones à faibles émissions dans
la loi les zones à faible émission c'est
effectivement des zones où certains
véhicules les plus polluants ne pourront
plus rentrés ont fait pas ça pour
embêter le mans ont fait ça parce que il
ya quarante mille personnes qui meurent
de la politique on va en parler de cette
question mais juste pour finir sur les
éoliennes puisque vous le dites vous
êtes des autres ans xavier bertrand s'il
est réélu président de région il promet
de subventionner les associations qui
déposeront des recours devant les
tribunaux qu'est ce que vous pensez de
ça ces associations n'ont pas besoin de
ça sont déjà très largement
subventionnés et moi je suis assez
désolé de voir que dans les hauts de
france le débat soit finalement très bas
de gamme puisque c'est haro sur les
éoliennes on à graviers bertrand qui n'a
fait son cheval de bataille je ne sais
pas ce qu'il propose parce que moi je
veux bien qu'on ne veuille pas de
certains types d'énergie mais dans ces
cas là il faut proposer faut dire qu'est
ce qu'on met à la place le front
national c'est pareil finalement moi je
suis assez je trouve que du coup dans ce
débat sur les régionales d hôtes france
on a
finalement une figure qui se révèle et
que en tout cas qui serait même pour moi
écologistes qui qui est leur empiétera
jet ski qui je n'attendais pas sur ce
sujet là qui est quelqu'un qui mène sa
liste et qu'il amène plutôt bien et que
je n'attendais pas sur le courage pour
justement refusé refuser les caricatures
et refusé que le débat soit confisquée
comme ça sur les énergies en l'église st
berne a eu le courage dans ce territoire
de défendre le développement de l'éolien
et jeu franchement je lui tire mon
chapeau un dernier mot sur ce sujet
avant de passer à autre chose puisque
emmanuel macron il était dans le hot
france hier et lui-même indique par
exemple dans l'aisne ya trop d'éoliennes
est ce qu'il n'ya pas aussi un problème
de répartition
et pour compléter vous visez combien
d'éoliennes en france
alors d'abord on ne peut pas dire
combien d'éoliennes il faut regarder en
termes de puissance parce que
aujourd'hui vous avez aujourd'hui vous
avez des éoliennes qu'on va pouvoir
remplacer d'ailleurs qui commencent à
arriver en fin de vie qu'on va pouvoir
remplacer par souvent deux fois moins
d'éoliennes sur le même parc parce que
maintenant avec les nouvelles
technologies et sont plus puissantes
donc on en aura besoin de moins ce qui
est ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
que on a des objectifs nationaux
rien n'a été fait avant pour que ces
objectifs soient déclinées en territoire
et c'est ce qu'on fait dans la loi
climat résilience dans la loi tepa
résilience on va faire en sorte que
chaque région décline ses objectifs pour
que ce soit bien répartis c'est vrai
qu'il ya pas de raison que certaines
régions fassent plus d'efforts que
d'autres parce que après l'électricité n
arrive à tout le monde et donc moi dans
ma région il ya eu des efforts qui ont
été faits inégalement réparties donc
quand on regarde la répartition en
fonction de là où c'est possible bien
sûr d'où la cartographie je trouve que
ce sera plus un ça permettra tout le
monde de se projeter et ça permettra de
d'enlever ce sentiment qu'ont certains
de faire plus d'efforts que d'autres
toujours sur la loi climat où j'avais
vais y ait un rééquilibrage entre
l'avion et le train
en parallèle on assiste à des
initiatives locales comme celle entre
vannes et belle île en mer où une ligne
aérienne vient d'être ouverte pour
transporter neuf passagers sont
régulières vous en pensez-quoi où en
tant que ministre
j'en pense que on va pas tout régler
dans la loi mais que ce que je veux moi
c'est qu'on fasse prendre conscience aux
gens de ce que ça veut dire de se
déplacer et de ce que ça implique en
termes d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre après on a interdit on a on va
interdire dans la loi de prendre un
avion quand on peut faire le même trajet
en train en moins de 2h30
on va pas régler tous les problèmes ça
concerne quelques lignes mais c'est
vraiment donné l'impulsion d'une
création en lui mais je découvre en
cette histoire là je trouve que
franchement il ya certainement d'autres
manières de faire après j'ai pas j'ai
pas les détails parce qu'après si après
tout si c'est si ça se fait je sais pas
moi en ulm ou en avion électrique
l'autre des mesures de ce texte était un
peu une mesure phare c'était la création
du délit d' écocide supprimé par les
sénateurs de la manière dont vous l'avez
écrit jugé incohérent et ambigu même les
écologistes au sénat ils ont soutenu la
droite sénatoriale sur ce sujet disant
que ça mettait fin à une forme
d'hypocrisie du gouvernement que
l'ecosite ça doit être un crime est pas
un délit qu'est ce que vous avez pensé
de ça mais ça alors ça confirme un peu
les inquiétudes que j'avais au départ
sur ce passage au sénat j'avais je
venais avec plutôt un état d'esprit
constructif en me disant ils me disent
qu'ils sont très ambitieux qu'ils ont
envie de faire avancer les choses et
cetera
donc tant mieux chouette et
malheureusement la plus l'examen avance
plus mes inquiétudes se confier un cerf
que
on fait alors on en force au fond ce
quelques portes ouvertes avec l'article
qui a été mis en tout début de texte qui
dit qu'on doit donc on doit respecter
nos engagements internationaux
c'est un enfant sage de portes ouvertes
s'il s'avère que c'est la hiérarchie des
normes donc c'est comme ça ça vous il
sert à rien les sénateurs même
écologistes ils disent que vous
arriverez plus forte à la coop 26,2
glagow de la coop 26 de glasgow avec cet
article c'est pas normal moi je crois
qu'on n'arrivera plus fort à la coop de
glasgow si on arrête les débats idiot
sur un certain nombre de sujets et si
tout le monde pousse pour aller ensemble
par contre j'arriverai plus forte sur à
glasgow
s'il n'y a pas des des reculs qui sont
entérinés parce que là on nous dit qu'on
est ambitieux et j'ai un recul sur les
zones à faible émission on repousse de
cinq ans c'est à dire qu'on attend 10
ans la pollution c'est maintenant il
faut attendre dix ans pour mettre en
place et des feux c'est ça que demandent
les sénateurs les menus végétariens qui
était une avancée on recule sur les
menus végétariens
on a la publicité j'ai même des mesures
un peu symbolique mais qui sont fortes
sur notre nom et l'encerclement on
parlait de l'encerclement sur sur les
éoliennes qui était mal ressentie par
certains annonceurs comme en de la
publicité je veux supprimer la publicité
quand on est sur les plats dans les
avions sur les bateaux qui se met pour
ça même ça ils veulent pas c'est donc
moi qu'on ne me dise pas qu'on est
ambitieux quand on recule sur des choses
comme ça ils veulent aussi reculé sur la
fin des passoires d'un pas les passoires
thermiques mais sur les oeufs sur
l'interdiction des locations d e.on à
2,6 me en logement où on va devoir
encore attendre
mais bon sang non ce n'est pas possible
d'avoir des reculs comme ça on a eu un
recul hier graves sur la continuité
écologique des cours d'eau
c'est à dire que là on avait trouvé des
moyens de pouvoir concilier le
patrimoine c'est et les fameuses
affaires de moulins et la continuité
écologique des cours d'eau c'est à dire
la qualité de l'eau des cours d'eau
c'est à dire les écosystèmes on avait
trouvé un équilibre et bien la démagogie
l'a emporté et donc on se retrouve là
avec un recul grave pour l'environnement
qui a été entérinée hier par les
sénateurs
qu'on ne me dise pas qu'on est ambitieux
pour l'environnement quand on prend des
décisions pareilles ils sont démagogues
pour vous les sénateurs dans l'examen de
ce texte à bas sur la sphère des moins
c'est clairement de la démagogie
alors eux ils disent qu'il n'y a pas
suffisamment de mesures d'accompagnement
dans ce texte notamment pour les plus
modestes
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ça mais je
réponds que j étais particulièrement
attentive
vous savez la crise et gilet jaune
c'était sain finalement c'était qu' il y
avait une bonne mesure la taxation du
carbone est une bonne mesure d'une
manière générale sauf que on n'a pas
assez et collectivement on n'a pas assez
entendu les difficultés que ça pouvait
créer au quotidien pour un certain
nombre de gens et donc ça on en tire des
leçons
donc aujourd'hui par exemple pour les
aider feu ont dit à des votes des
voitures qu'elles pourront pu rentrer
dans ces zones alors attention là on
parle de voitures qui ont entre 18 et 25
ans entre 15 et 25 ans sachant que en
gros au bout de 18 ans le turnover des
voitures est assez et se fait
naturellement entre guillemets donc ça
concerne pas tant de voitures que ça
mais n'empêche il faut que les personnes
puissent être aidé dans les et des feux
on va pouvoir avoir jusqu'à 12000 euros
dead pour pouvoir changer sa voiture
dix-neuf mineurs odette dans la
métropole du grand paris parce que les
aides se cumule avec des aides du grand
paris et puis on aura aussi des aides
pour des voitures qui ne sont pas neufs
puisque vous savez que les voitures que
les personnes qui ont plus de
difficultés financières n'achètent pas
des voitures neuves
donc on a des êtres qui sont données on
a investi énormément pour les transports
en commun pour pouvoir remettre des
transports en commun on a investi pour
mettre en place et votre co voiturage on
investit aussi sur le vélo qui est une
alternative qui s'est beaucoup
développée bref on ce qu'on veut c'est
que les personnes puissent continuer à
se déplacer casey moyen de me faire
facilement
voilà une des leçons des gilet jaune et
ça je pourrais vous donner des noms
comme ça sur toutes les mesures qui sont
prises dans la loi
si on vous suit un accord entre députés
et sénateurs paraît compromis abel a
plus on avance plus ça me paraît
difficile oui un dernier mot une
dernière question d'actualité sur anne
hidalgo
vous parliez du vélo du thermique aussi
anne hidalgo veut rendre payant le
stationnement des deux roues dans paris
c'est une bonne initiative mais j'ai
entendu ça après il faut réguler les
choses
moi je compare nos sources scooter
électrique précise oui donc c'est à dire
les d'euros les doro thermique ya une
norme développement des deux roues à
paris ça se voit ça a une influence sur
la circulation
il ya un partage de l'espace qui doit
être fait pour tout le monde je
comprends qu'elles puissent demander à
ce que healy et inversement pour
l'occupation de l'espace public parce
que c'est vrai que les deux roues ont
cet avantage de moi occuper l'espace
public mais maintenant ils sont très
très nombreux et me faisant moi-même du
deux roues pour trouver une place c'est
compliqué donc je peux peut-être qu'elle
a raison de son point de vue elle a les
éléments pas moi mais de devoir régler
ça vous êtes vous la soutenez plutôt
dans cette mesure mais je considère que
il quand on doit réguler ce genre de
choses il faut s'en donner les moyens
merci beaucoup merci marc van peel et
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin on va
continuer bien sûr à suivre
l'examen de cette loi climat au sénat on
regarde la une du progrès carburant plus
cher c'est le dans tous les journaux du
groupe ebra aujourd'hui d'ailleurs à
brive parce que les vacances vont être
un petit peu plus cher cette année
merci beaucoup merci par un pompier
litres
[Musique]